welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday among the changes from any high
school students in this pandemic year
they are taking advanced placement tests
from home hoping to score high enough to
earn up to a full year's worth of
college credit in a particular subject
but many students say they've run into
trouble with the online tests and the
College Board which administers them is
even the subject of a class-action
lawsuit by parents as a result as
millions of high school students began
taking AP exams from home last week do
you have 20 minutes to read the question
not everything went as planned the
submit button doesn't work take Ella boo
back a junior at Blue Mountain High
School in Pennsylvania I was just
thinking this is unbelievable I was
clicking submit and nothing happened it
was like the submit button was just
frozen what went through your mind I was
frustrated I was nervous about it I
didn't know if there was anything I did
wrong AP tests are typically in-person
exams that lasts between three to four
hours with multiple choice short answer
and essay questions you can use any
device to take this exam but test
administered during the pandemic we're
online lasted 45 minutes and consisted
of only free response question as I
think is a lot more difficult than in
the past
retired teacher Mike Byrne scored AP
History exams for the College Board for
more than a decade he says this year's
changes are cause for concern it's going
to be given by a computer do all
students have computers and computer
access that would allow them to do this
my exam was that night or the night
Enrique Castro is a senior at Kubasaki
High School a Department of Defense
School in Okinawa Japan he took five AP
exams because tests in each subject were
administered at the same time for all
students he had to take his in the
middle of the night do you think it puts
you at a disadvantage because you were
obviously taking an exam at a time where
he should have been sleeping yes it was
out of my routine how did it go for your
AP exams
US government and went extremely well my
calculus bc exam i had to submit
pictures
unfortunately the college board did not
receive my responses because they did
not load in time right after i had been
told that my responses were not
submitted i went outside and said
outside the front of the house for about
a good 45 minutes and just kind of
stared blank into the distance the
College Board says students who
experienced issues during the first week
of testing can take makeup exams in June
a small consolation for students like
Enrique Castro and Ella Bou Beck I'm
gonna try to do as best as I can and do
even better than I would have and I feel
like that's the only thing we really can
do at this point if this teaches
anything from the class of 2020 is the
fact that we to get the job done and we
have no other option well the College
Board says that the majority of students
were actually able to take the exams
successfully and complete them but
earlier this week they did make email
submissions a backup option for those
that had technical difficulties that
does not include the week one test
takers like the students we spoke with
who have to settle for taking those
makeup exams and Jeff if you remember if
you took AP exams nobody wants to take
those as a makeup exam once you've done
it once already
very good point Dana indeed